- I love a reading.
- Oh!
- I love all the things,
but actually in my family,
like I come from a long
line of spiritually,
I don't know, enlightened people.
Like my mother has what we
always called a really strong intuition.
And she could always
kinda sniff things out.
And even when we were younger,
she always knew what was going
on in our lives before we said anything.
And my grandmother as well, and my brother
is actually properly able to read,
and he will know things
that I never even told him,
which is really wonderful.
- Wow.
- So I don't question it
- But kinda not
if you wanna keep a secret.
(audience laughing)
- I'm very much so held
accountable in my family.
- (laughing) I was gonna say.
- I'm like "Oh gosh,"
- That's harsh. (laughs)
- "there's really no pulling
the wool over your eyes."
"There's nothing"
"going on here."
- You just have to lie.
No it's not.
It's not real
- And I am a bad actor
when it comes to reality.
(laughing)
I'm like, "Oh god, I can't lie to you!"
- I love it!
- I'm getting hives everywhere.